the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I wanted to give you some
context for why we're learning about all
the Neutron stuff and go over all the
reactor types that until this year the
first time you learned about the non
light water reactors at MIT was once you
left MIT I remember that as an undergrad
as well the only exposure we had to non
light water reactors is in our design
course because we decided to design one
so I wanted to show you guys all the
different types of reactors are out
there how they work and start generating
and marinating in all the different
variables and nomenclature that we'll
use to develop the neutron transport and
Neutron diffusion equations the nice
part is now until quiz 2 you can pretty
much forget about the concept of charge
so 802 can go back on the shelf because
every interaction we do here is neutral
charge neutral there'll be radioactive
decays that are not the case but
everything Neutron is neutral doesn't
mean it's going to be simple it's just
gonna be different but in the meantime
today is not going to be particularly
intense but I do want to show you where
we're going and this goes with the
pedagogical switch that we made in this
department starting this year and you
guys are the first trial of this we're
switching to context first in theory
second I personally find it much more
interesting to study the theory of
something for which I know the
application exists who here would agree
just about actually everybody ok yeah
that's what I thought too so in the end
we had arguments amongst the Faculty of
all well you have to learn the theory to
understand the application and that
works really well when you say it behind
the closed office door by yourself but
the fact is I'm in it for yeah I'm in it
for a maximum subject matter retention
so in whatever order that works the best
and sounds like for you guys this works
the best that's what we're doing with
the whole undergrad curriculum not just
this class so let's launch into all the
different methods of making nuclear
power both fission and fusion and to
switch gears since we're dealing with
neutrons I don't know what happened with
the oh there we go the idea here is that
neutrons hit things like uranium and
plutonium the fizzle isotopes that you
guys saw in the exam and caused the
release of other neutrons
as we come up with these variables I'm
gonna start laying them out here it
might take more than a board to fill
them all and I'll warn you ahead of time
this is the only time in this course
that we're gonna have V and knew the
Greek letter nu on the board at the same
time and I'm gonna make it really
obvious which one is nu and which one is
V so this parameter that describes how
many neutrons come out from each fission
reaction we refer to as nu or the
average number you'll see in the data
tables as nu bar and so as we come up
with these sorts of things I will start
going over them and the idea here is
that each uranium-235 or plutonium or
whatever nucleus B gets two to three
neutrons the exact number for which is
still under a hot debate and I don't
think it actually matters we'll make a
couple of fission products that take
away most of the heat of the nuclear
reaction and I just want to stop there
even though you know there's going to be
a chain reaction and that's what makes
nuclear power happen and we can go over
the timeline of what actually happens in
fission and what kind of a nuclear
reaction it really is so in this case
this is a reaction where a neutron is
heading towards this time are actually
gonna give it a label a uranium-235
nucleus and it very temporarily like I
showed you yesterday forms a compound
nucleus some sort of large excited
nucleus that lasts for about ten to the
minus fourteen seconds so it doesn't
instantly fizz apart there's actually a
neutron absorption event some sort of
nuclear instability at which point your
two fission products break off
notice you don't have let's call them
fission product one and fission product
to notice you don't quite have any
neutrons yet Neutron production is not
instantaneous for the following reason
if you remember back to nuclear
stability when we plotted let's say n I
think that was maybe Z and this was N
and I think this was a homework problem
and you had to come up with some sort of
curve of best fit for the most stable
come combination of n and Z for a
nucleus it was not a straight line it
was something on the order of like N
equals like what is it
1.00 5 5 z plus some constant something
with a rather small slope well if you
have a heavy nucleus like uranium-235
and you split it apart evenly let's just
pretend it splits evenly for now you're
kind of splitting that nucleus along a
rather unstable line and as you saw in
the semi empirical mass formula a little
bit of instability goes a really long
way towards making the nucleus extremely
unstable so let's say you'd make a
couple of fission products that just
cleave that just cleave that nucleus
with the same proportion of protons and
neutrons how would they decay or how can
they decay there's a couple different
ways what do you guys think
it can emit neutrons if it's really
unstable at which point it would just go
down a neutron number or how else could
it decay
alpha decay let's see yeah a lot of
those will the heavier ones tend to do
alpha decays what would it do at alpha
decay for alpha you guys have we go in
that direction right yeah you know what
I'm not gonna rule that out yet so let's
let's go with that how else could they
decay yeah through beta decay let's say
in that direction
pretty much all these happen just not
necessarily in this order when you have
a really really asymmetric nucleus a lot
of these fission products will emit
neutrons almost instantaneously in the
realm of like 10 to the minus 17 seconds
some incredibly short time line you'll
start to decay downwards a little bit
but you're not quite at the stability
line which is why a lot of the fission
products then go on and they deposit
their kinetic energy by bouncing around
the different atoms and material
creating heat but a lot of them will
also send off betas or gammas and it may
take you know ten to the minus thirteen
seconds for them to whatever the
half-life of that particular isotope is
and after around like ten to the let's
say 10 to the minus 10 to 10 to the
minus six seconds depending on the
isotope in the medium those two fission
products will stop and let's just say
that they stop there so the whole
process of fission it's actually quite a
compound process first the neutron is
absorbed forming a compound nucleus then
it splits apart then those individual
fission products undergo what ever
decays suit them best and that's the
source of the neutrons in fission
sometimes one of those fission products
might be particularly unstable and it
might send off two neutrons in other
cases that I don't know of it one off
the top of my head it might be none but
this is the whole timeline of events in
fission and the justification for why
this happens straight from the first
month to 2201 and I wanted to pull up
some of the nuclear data so you can see
what these values tend to look like
and also where to find them I've got to
do that screen cloning thing again hey
there we go
so I've already pre pulled up the Janus
library I've already clicked on
uranium-235 thanks to you guys I have
all the data now on my shirt but so you
can see a little better I also have it
on the screen so let's look at this
value right here a new bar total neutron
production and I'll make it bigger so
it's easier to see did I click on the
right one yeah so take a look at that
then total number of neutrons produced
during u-235 it's for most energies it's
hovering around the 2.4 or so there's
been arguments about whether it's two
point four three or two point four four
and that's a linear scale that's not
very helpful let's go to a logarithmic
scale that's more like what I'm used to
seeing most of the fission happens for
u-235 in the thermal region in the
region where the neutrons are at values
let's say the cutoff usually about one
electron volt or lower in average energy
and noubar is fantastically constant at
that level then as you go up and up in
energy you start to make more and more
neutrons why do you guys think that
would be the case
what are you doing to that compound
nucleus as you increase the incoming
Neutron energy it's gonna have more
energy itself you might excite other
nuclear states that can then lead to
other sorts of decays or other neutron
emission so to me that's the reason why
once you hit about 1 MeV you can start
to see a lot more neutrons being given
off the reason we usually treat this as
a constant notice I haven't given it an
energy dependence is because most of the
fission that happens is at thermal
energies for that I want to show you the
fission cross-section there's a lot of
cross-sections and it's probably gonna
be in a different graph because it's in
different units and this gives you a
rough measure per atom what's the
probability of fission happening as a
function of incoming Neutron energy at
those high energies you have relatively
low cross sections or low probabilities
of fission happening then there's this
crazy resonance region that looks like a
sideways mustache but then as you get
down to the lower energy levels it gets
much more in fact exponentially more
likely that fission will happen so
almost all the fissioning in a light
water reactor or any sort of other
thermal reactor happens at thermal
energies and that's why we take nu bar
as a constant you don't have to
especially if you're analyzing what's
called a fast reactor or a reactor whose
Neutron population remains fast on
purpose and so with that I want to
launch into some of the different types
of reactors that you might see you guys
already did those calculations in
problem set 1 so I don't have to repeat
them for you let's get right into the
acronym so if you haven't figured this
out already nuclear is a pretty acronym
dense field does anyone can anyone say
they know all the acronyms on this slide
you're gonna know about 90% of them in
about 90 minutes so it's okay or you'll
have seen them at least and you look
completely unfamiliar
most of them well let's knock them off
so KN last Thursday already showed you
the basic layout of a boiling water
reactor one of the types of light water
reactors and the reason that this is a
thermal reactor is because it's full of
water water as we saw in our old Q
equation argument is very good at
stopping neutrons because if you guys
remember this the maximum change in
energy that a neutron can get is related
to alpha times its incoming energy where
this alpha is just a minus 1 over a plus
1 squared and I think this should
actually be a 1 minus right there a is
that mass number of whatever the
neutrons are hitting and that one comes
directly from the neutron mass number if
you remember this was the simplest
reduction of the Q equation the
generalized Q equation or kinematics
that we looked at when I said let's do
the general form and okay let's take the
simplest form Neutron elastic scattering
here's where it comes back if a neutron
hits water which is made mostly a
hydrogen and a is one then it can
transfer a maximum of all of its energy
to the let's say to that hydrogen atom
therefore given the neutron no energy
and thermal izing it or slowing it down
very quickly to show you what one of
these things actually looks like that's
the underside of a BWR I don't know if K
did K and show you this before okay
you've already seen what this generally
looks like what about the turbine does
anyone actually seen a turbine this size
close up gigawatt electric turbine
trying to see which one of those pixels
is a person so I'm person-sized
I don't see anything persons oh there's
a ladder that looks to be about 6 feet
tall so give you guys a sense of scale
of the sort of turbines that we say oh
yeah we draw a turbine on our diagram
well it's not actually not simple these
things take up entire hallways they're
kind of airport hangar size buildings
never seen one of the you
but I've seen one in Japan there was a
lot cleaner than this but otherwise it
looked pretty much the same and the way
this actually works for those who
haven't taken any thermo classes yet is
this turbine is full of different sets
of blades that are curved at an angle so
that when steam shoots in it transfer
some of its energy to get the turbine
rotating and there's going to be a
generator found of an eye like an
alternator to generate the electricity
there which looks to be roughly a
hundred feet away just to give you a
sense of scale for this stuff as Kayne
showed you a pressurized water reactor
it's another kind of light water reactor
with what's called an indirect cycle so
this water stays pressurized it also
stays liquid which is good for Neutron
moderation or slowing down because in
addition to the probability of any
interaction some probability Sigma if
you want to get the total reaction
probability you have to multiply by its
number density to get a macroscopic
cross-section this is why I introduced
this stuff Y at the beginning of class
so you'd have time to marinate in it and
then bring it back and remember what it
was all about and so every single
reaction that goes on in a nuclear
reactor has got its own cross section
will probably need half the board for
this one you can say you have a total
microscopic cross-section these are all
going to be as a function of neutron
energy what's the probability of
anything happening at all and these are
actually tabulated up on the janice
website so let's unclick that get rid of
neutron production and go all the way to
the top n comma total so all this stuff
is written in nuclear reaction parlance
where if you have let's say n comma
total that means a neutron comes in and
that's the reaction that you're looking
at so this data file here once I open it
up will give you the probability that
anything at all will happen you can see
as the neutron energy gets higher the
probability of anything happening at all
gets less and less
less and it follows the shape of most of
the other cross-sections and I'm going
to leave this up right there you've also
got a few different kinds of reactions
like you can have a scatter let's call
that scatter which we've already said
can either be elastic or inelastic it
may not matter to us from the point of
view of neutron physics whether the
collision is elastic or inelastic all
that matters is the neutron goes in and
a slower Neutron comes out because what
we're really concerned with here is
tracking the full population of neutrons
at any point in the reactor so we'll
give this a position vector R which has
just got x y and z in it or whatever
other coordinate system you might happen
to you is I prefer Cartesian because it
makes sense at every energy going in any
direction so we now have a solid angle
vector that's got both theta and Phi in
it at any given time and the whole goal
of what we're going to be doing today
and all of next week is to find out how
do you solve for and simplify this
population of neutrons
let's see make sure to fill that in as
velocity
yes
and so a lot of let's see let me get
back to the cross sections and stuff if
we want to know how many neutrons are in
a certain little volume element in some
D volume in some certain little
increment of energy de traveling in some
very small solid angle D Omega
supposedly if you have this function
then you know the direction and location
and speed of every single Neutron
everywhere in the reactor and this is
eventually what the goal of things like
Ben and cords group does the
computational reactor physics group is
solve for this or a simplified version
of it over and over and over again for
different sorts of geometries and in
order to do so you need to know the
rates of reactions of every kind of
possible reaction that could take a
neutron out of its current position like
if it happens to be moving which most of
them are out of its current energy group
which pretty much any reaction will
cause the neutron to lose energy what's
the only reaction we've talked about
where the neutron loses absolutely no
energy it's a type of scattering
yep exactly forward scattering so for
forward scattering for that case where
theta scattering equals zero again
that's you missed the neutron didn't
actually change direction at all and
therefore it didn't transfer any energy
but for everything else for every other
possible reaction there's gonna be an
energy change associated with it and
probably some corresponding change in
angle because a neutron can't just be
moving and hit something and continue
moving more slowly there's got to be
some change in momentum to balance along
with that change of energy and it might
slightly move in some different
direction
and all this is happening as a function
of time as you can see this gets pretty
hairy pretty quick and that's why we put
the full equation for this on our
department t-shirts but no one ever
solves the full thing what we're gonna
be going over is how do you simplify it
into something you can solve with like
pen and paper or possibly a gigantic
computer but it's not impossible so
inside this Sigma total we talked about
different scattering and then you could
have absorption in all its different
forms
what sort of reactions with a neutron
would cause it to be absorbed
yes vision thank you so there's going to
be some Sigma fission cross-section as a
function of energy and if it doesn't
fizz but it is absorbed we'll call that
capture
but capture can mean a whole bunch of
different things to right there could be
also a whole bunch of other nuclear
reactions like there could be a reaction
where one Neutron comes in two no
neutrons go out like we looked at with
beryllium in the Chadwick paper from the
first day
we're like what actually does exist for
this stuff so Janice doesn't like
multi-touch so have to bear with me on
the small print on the screen but there
should be up here it is cross-section
number 16 there is a probability that
one Neutron goes in that Z right there
is whatever your incoming particle
happens to be and in this case we know
it's a neutron because we picked
incident Neutron data and two n means
two neutrons come out let's plot that
cross-section you can see that the value
is zero until you hit about four or five
oh it's actually five point two nine
seven seven eight one MeV so that's the
Q value at which this particular
reaction happens to turn on might be
responsible for a little bit of the blip
in the total cross-section so
technically if we were to turn on every
single cross-section in this database it
should add up to that red line right
there so you can start to get an idea
for how much of all the reactions of
uranium-235 are due to fission that's
the one we want to exploit
so let's find fission right down there
oh wow there's a 3n reaction I want to
see that that doesn't happen until 12
MeV yeah so neutrons don't typically
tend to hit 12 MeV in a fission reactor
so this is a flute and the perfect
flimsy pretext to bring in another
variable it's called the Chi spectrum or
what's called the fission birth spectrum
yeah we've already talked about the
neutrons being born and how many there
were but we're didn't say at what energy
they're born in fusion reactors this is
pretty simple
you've already looked at this case what
is it fourteen point seven MeV that's a
lot simpler
that's the fusion for fission it's not
so simple for the case of fission if you
draw energy versus this Chi spectrum it
takes an interesting looking curve from
about one MeV to about ten MeV with the
most likely energy being around to
anything so you aren't really going to
get neutrons at the energy required for
a three n reaction in a regular fission
reactor just not gonna happen but it's
good that you know that that exists so
let's go and answer my original question
how much of the total cross-section is
due to fission most of it especially at
low energies so let me get rid of those
two n and 3n ones because they're kind
of ruining our data it's making it
harder to see
that's better so you can see at energies
below around let's say a KETV or so
almost all of the reactions happening
with neutrons in uranium-235 are fission
this is part of what makes it such a
particularly good isotope to use in
reactors the other one is you can find
it in the ground
unlike most the other fissile isotopes
unlike I think any of the other fissile
isotopes thorium you got to breed and
turn it into uranium 233 have to think
about that one but then you can start to
look at what are the other components of
this cross-section like ZN prime in
elastic scattering which doesn't turn on
until about 0.002 MeV but later on is
one of the major contributors and
actually is responsible for and I've
brought this for a reason is responsible
for that little bump in the total
cross-section so eventually all these
things do matter but let's think about
which ones we actually care about at all
because what we eventually want to do is
develop some sort of Neutron balance
equation if we can measure the change in
the number of neutrons as a function of
position energy angle and time as a
function of time and that would probably
be a partial derivative because there's
like seven variables here before I write
any equations it's just going to be a
measure of the gains minus the losses
and while every particular reaction has
its own cross section there's only going
to be a few that we care about like
they'll only be one or two types of
reactions that can result in a gain of
the neutron population into a certain
volume with a certain energy with a
certain angle and for losses there's
only one we really care about total
because any interaction with a neutron
is going to cause that Neutron to leave
this little group of perfect position
energy and angle
so that's where we're going we'll
probably start down that route on
Tuesday because I promised you guys
context today you've all been to the MIT
research reactor a couple of you are you
running it yet awesome okay yeah say
that Bo so yeah so Sarah and Jared's
doing that anyone else
training or trained no I'd say the folks
usually pretty scared when they find out
mit has a reactor and they're even more
scared when they find out you guys run
it what they don't realize is there's
been basically no problem since 1954 the
only one I know of as someone fell
asleep at the controls once and forgot
to push the don't call FoxNews button
and it called Fox News or something so
there was a big story about asleep at
the helm
Nora knew alarms and passive safety
systems and backup operators and
everything else that actually made sure
that nothing happened but nowadays
correct me if I'm wrong you actually
have to get up every half hour reach
around a panel and hit a button right so
you want to hit it before it beeps at
you
it's reminding you okay
okay yeah I'd heard the buttons every
half-hour gotcha cool yeah so for all
use watching on camera whatever just
know that these guys got it under
control so onto some gas cooled reactors
and to explain some of these acronyms
there are some that use natural uranium
though all the ones pretty much all the
ones in this country you need to enrich
the uranium to get enough u-235 to turn
the reaction on but that's not actually
you don't have to do that in every case
and you'll also see these acronyms
Leu meu or h EU standing for low medium
or high enrichment the accepted standard
for what's low enriched uranium is 20%
or below an interesting fact though you
can't have something at 19 what at 19
point 99 percent enriched uranium and
expect it to be low enriched uranium
because every measurement technique has
some error and what really determines if
it's Leu is when an inspector comes and
takes a sample it better be below 20%
including their error so you'll usually
see 19 point 75% given as the Leu limit
because there's always some processing
error in homogeneities measurement error
head your bets
pretty much like in england or the UK
the advanced gas reactors have been
churning along for decades they actually
use co2 as the coolant which is
relatively inert and they use graphite
as the moderator so in this case the
coolant in the moderator are separate
unlike the light water reactors we have
so this way the graphite right here just
sits in solid form and slows down those
neutrons not quite as good as water but
pretty good there is an issue though
that co2 just like anything has a
natural decomposition reaction where co2
naturally is in equilibrium with CO and
O 2 and O 2 plus graphite yields co2 gas
graphite was solid and talking with a
couple folks from the National Nuclear
Laboratory they said that 40 years later
when they took the caps off these
reactors a lot of that graphite was just
gone with a good explanation it
vaporized very very very slowly over 40
earth years or so
due to this natural recombination with
whatever little bit of o2 is an
equilibrium with co2 and possibly some
other leaks I'm sure I wouldn't have
been told that if there was a leak so
I'd say the feasibility is high because
they've been running for almost half a
century the power density is very low
why do you guys think that's the case
yeah
mm-hmm
absolutely so well let's say you need
the same cooling capacity but you're
right co2 even if pressurized is not a
good at heat transfer medium as water
water's dense it's also got one of the
highest heat capacities of anything
we've ever seen the other reason is
right here if you want enough reaction
density it not only matters what the per
atom density is but what the number
density is and if you're using gaseous
co2 coolant even if it's pressurized
there are fewer reactions happening per
unit volume because there are a few co2
molecules per unit volume than water
would have so that's why we pressurize
our light water reactors to keep water
in its liquid state where it's a great
heat absorber takes a lot of energy to
boil it and it's really dense so it's a
very effective dense moderator these
have been around forever I think when
did Windscale happen when scale was also
the source of an interesting fire that's
you guys might want to know about it's
one of those only nuclear disasters that
hit seven on the arbitrary unit scale I
don't quite know how they determine
what's a seven but there was a fire at
the wind scale plan due to the build-up
of what's called Wigner energy it turns
out that when neutrons go slamming
around in the graphite they leave behind
radiation damage and when my family
always explained what do you do for a
living and I just can only think well
they don't know radiation damage they've
watched Harry Potter I like to say
radiation like dark magic leaves traces
well it leaves traces in the graphite in
the form of atomic defense which took
energy to create so by causing damage to
the graphite you store energy in it
which is known as Wigner energy and you
can store so much that it just catches
fire and explodes sometimes that's what
happened here at Windscale eleven tons
of uranium ended up burning because all
of a sudden the temperature in the graph
I just started going up for no reason no
reason that they understood at the time
it turns out that they had built up
enough radiation damage energy that it
started releasing more heat and
releasing more heat caused more of that
energy to be released and it was
self-perpetuating
until it just caught fire and burned 11
tonnes of uranium out in the countryside
this was 1957 so again a seven on the
scale with no units of nuclear disasters
argue it's probably not as bad as
Chernobyl so they might want a little
bit of sort of resolution in that scale
there's another type of gas cool reactor
called the pebble bed modular reactor a
much more up-and-coming one or each fuel
element you don't have fuel rods you've
actually got little pebbles full of tiny
kernels of fuel so you've got a built in
graphite moderator tennis ball sized
thing with lots of little grains of sand
of uo2 cooled by a bed of flowing helium
or something like that and then that
helium or the other gas transfers heat
to water which goes into make steam and
goes into the turbine like I showed you
before so this is what's the fuel
actually looks like inside each one of
these tennis balls spheres of mostly
graphite there's these little kernels of
uranium dioxide about a half a
millimeter across covered in layers of
silicon carbide a really strong and
dense material that keeps the fission
products in because the biggest danger
from nuclear fuel is the highly
radioactive fission products that due to
their instability are giving off all
sorts of awful for anywhere from
milliseconds to mega years after reactor
operation and so if you keep those out
of the coolant then the coolant stays
relatively non radioactive and it's safe
to do things like maintain the plant
then there's the very high temperature
reactor the ultimate in acronym
creativity it operates at a very high
temperature which has been steadily
decreasing over time as reality has
caught up to expectations when I first
got into this field they were saying
we're gonna run this at 1,100 Celsius
then I started studying material science
and I was like yeah nothing wants to be
at 1,100 Celsius by that time they
downgraded it to a thousand now they've
asked some toda at around 800 850 due to
some actual problems in operating things
in helium it's not the helium itself but
the impurities in the helium that could
really mess
you up and the sorts of alloys that they
need to get this working these nickel
super alloys like alloy 230 they can
slightly carburized ich arbor eyes
depending on the amount of carbon and
the helium coolant either way you go you
lose the strength that you need so I'll
say feasibility is low to medium because
well I haven't really seen one of these
yet then onto water-cooled reactors has
anyone heard hear heard of the reactors
they have in Canada the CANDU reactors
that's my favorite acronym hope that was
intentional is what yeah it's not like
the well they're not sorry about
anything but whatever
at any rate one of the nice features
about this is you can actually use
natural uranium because the moderators
heavy water you have to look into what
the sort of cross-sections are even
though deuterium won't slow down
neutrons as much as hydrogen will or my
alpha thing oh it was right here all
along even though a is two instead of
one for deuterium its absorption
cross-section or specifically yeah
because it doesn't fish in its
absorption cross-section is way lower
than that of water
so you actually it actually functions as
a better moderator because fewer of
those collisions are absorption and
because you have a better Neutron
population and less absorption you don't
need to enrich your uranium you also
don't need to pressurize your moderator
so you can flow some other coolant
through these pressure tubes and just
have a big tank of close to something
room temperature unpressurized e2o
as your moderator problem with that is
d2 is expensive anyone priced out
deuterium oxide before probably have it
the reactor because I know you have
drums of it
a couple thousand a kilo it's an
expensive bottle of water
it'll also mess you up if you drink it
because a lot of that even if it's you
know crystal-clear filtered d2o
a lot of what if sell your machinery
depends on the diffusion coefficients of
various things in water those solutes in
water and if you change the mass of the
water than the diffusion coefficients of
the water itself as well as the things
in it will change and if you depend on
let's say exact sodium and potassium
concentrations for your nerves to
function a little change in that can go
a long way towards giving you a bad day
and there's actually we have a little
piece of one of these pressure tubes
upstairs if anyone wants to take a look
there's all these sealed fuel bundles
inside what they call a calandria tube
just a pressurized tube that's
horizontal the problem with some of
these is if these spacers get knocked
out of place which they do all the time
those tubes can start to creep downward
and get a little harder to cool or touch
the sides and change thermal and now
getting into material signs it's it's a
mess then there's the old RBMK the
reactor that caused chernobyl you can
also use natural uranium or low enriched
uranium here the problem though that led
to turn out one of the many problems led
to Chernobyl was you've got all this
moderator right here so if you lose your
coolant let's say you had a light water
reactor and your coolant goes away your
moderator also goes away which means
your neutrons don't slow down anymore oh
that one reaction is messing up there we
go which means your neutrons don't slow
down anymore which means the probability
of fission happening could be like
10,000 times lower so losing coolant and
a light water reactor might temperature
might go up but it's not going to give
you a nuclear bad day in the RBMK
reactor it will and it did and in
addition the control rods which was
supposed to shut down the reaction made
of things like boron for carbide or
hafnium or something with a really high
capture cross-section we're tipped with
graphite to help them ease in so you've
got moderator tipped rods which induce
additional moderation which helps slow
down the
neutrons even more to where they fission
even better and that's what led to
what's called a positive feedback
coefficient so the more you tried to
insert the control rods and the more you
tried to fix things the worse things got
in the nuclear sense and in something
like a quarter of a second the reactor
power went up by like 35,000 times and
we'll do a millisecond by millisecond
rundown of what happened in Chernobyl
after we do all this Neutron physics
stuff when you'll be better equipped to
understand it but suffice to say there
were some positive coefficients here
that are to be avoided at all costs in
all nuclear reactor design and the
actual reactor Hall you can go and stand
on one of these things very different
design from what you're used to I don't
think anyone would let you stand on top
of a pressure vessel first your shoes
would melt because they're usually at
like 300 Celsius or so and second of all
you probably get this a little too much
radiation but this is actually what an
RBMK reactors all looks like for one of
the units that didn't blow up there were
multiple units at that site then there's
the supercritical water reactor let's
say you want to run at higher
temperatures than regular water will
allow you to you can pressurize it so
much that water goes beyond the
supercritical point in the phase sense
and starts to behave not like a slick
wicked liquid not like a gas but
somewhere in between something that's
really really dense so getting towards
the density of water not quite which
means it's still a great moderator but
still can cool the materials quite well
to extract heat to make power and so on
and so on yeah
ah good question for a supercritical
water reactor it most definitely refers
to the coolant it's the phase of the
coolant words beyond the liquid gas sort
of separation line and it's just
something in between any of these
reactors can go supercritical where
you're producing more neutrons than
you're consuming and that is a nuclear
bad day but the supercritical water
reactor does not refer to neutron
population just a coolant good question
it's never come up before but it's like
should've thought of that and so then my
favorite liquid metal reactors like LBE
or lead bismuth eutectic it's a low
melting point alloy of lead and bismuth
lead melts at around 330 Celsius bismuth
200-something
put them together and it's like a low
temperature solder it melted 123 point 5
Celsius you can melt it in a frying pan
this is nice because you don't want your
coolant to freeze when you're trying to
cool your reactor because imagine that
you something happens you lose power the
coolant freezes somewhere outside the
core you can't get the core cool again
that's called a loss of flow accident
that can lead to a really bad day and
the lower your melting point is the
better sodium potassium it's already
molten to begin with sodium melts at
like 90 C and when you add two different
metals together you almost always lower
the melting point of the combination in
this case forming what's called the
eutectic or a lowest possible melting
point alloy so the sodium fast reactor
has a number of advantages like you
don't really need any pressure as long
as you have a cover gas keeping the
sodium width from reacting with anything
like the moisture in the air or any
errant water in the room you can just
circulate it through the core and liquid
metals are awesome heat conductors they
might not have the best heat capacity as
in how much energy per gram they could
store like water but they're really good
conductors with very high thermal
conductivity they also are really good
at not slowing down neutrons so these
tend to be what's called fast reactors
that rely on the ability of other
isotopes of uranium like uranium 238 to
undergo what's called fast
vision and I want to show you what that
looks like let's pull up u-238 and look
at its fission cross-section and you
might find it should look a fair bit
different so we'll go down to number 18
to fission cross-section very very
different so u-238 is pretty terrible at
fission at low energies it's pretty good
at capturing neutrons this is where we
get plutonium 239 like you guys saw in
the exam but then you go to really high
energies and all of a sudden it gets
pretty good at undergoing fission on its
own and so the basis behind a lot of
fast reactors is a combination of making
their own fuel and the fact that uranium
238 fast visions even better than at
thermal visions so something good for
you to know even though it's not a
fissile fuel that's light water reactor
people talking you can get it to fission
if the neutron population is higher now
there's some problems with this it takes
some time for neutrons to slow down from
1 to 10 MeV to about 0.025 Evie if your
neutrons don't need to slow down and
travel anywhere it pretty much all they
have to do is be born and absorbed by a
nearby uranium atom the feedback time is
faster in these sorts of reactors
they're inherently more difficult to
control and you can't use normal physics
like thermal expansion of things that
might happen on the order of micro to
nanoseconds if it takes less time than
that for one Neutron to be born and find
another uranium atom you can still use
it somewhat but not quite as much so
it's something to note backed up by
nuclear data that's what one of them
actually looks like these things have
been built that's a blob of liquid
sodium on the Monju reactor in Japan and
where I was all last week in Russia they
actually have fleets of fast reactors
they're bien 300 and bien 600 reactors
are 3 and 600 megawatt sodium cool
reactors one of them in the Chelyabinsk
region they used for
much for desalination down in the center
of Russia where there's no oceans nearby
and probably dirty water they actually
use that to make clean water they also
use this for power production and for
radiation damage studies so when it
comes to radiation material science
these fast reactors are really where
it's at yeah you just notice the bottom
I went to Belgium to their National
Nuclear labs where they have a slowing
sodium test loop it's not a reactor but
it's like a thermal hydraulics and
materials test loop and I asked a simple
question where is the bathroom
and they started laughing at me they
said we're not putting any plumbing in a
sodium loop building you'll have to go
to the next building over and that's
when I noticed there weren't any
sprinkler systems or toilets but every
15 or 20 feet there was a giant barrel
of sand that's the fire extinguisher for
a liquid metal fire is you just cover it
with sand absorb the heat keep the air
out of the moisture out wick away the
moisture whatever else and does I don't
know but you can't use normal fire
extinguishers to put out a sodium fire
ah I don't know if that would work guess
it's worth a shot with glasses and
safety and stuff of course and the ones
that I spent the most time working on
like I showed you in the paper yesterday
is the LED or LED bismuth fast reactor
this one does not have the disadvantage
of exploding like sodium it does have
the disadvantage like I showed you
yesterday of corroding everything pretty
much everything and so the one thing
keeping this thing back was corrosion
and I say the outlet temperatures medium
but hotter soon hopefully someone picks
up our work and like yeah that was a
good idea because we think it can raise
the outlet temperature of a lead bismuth
reactor by like a hundred Celsius as
long as some other unforeseen problem
doesn't pop up and we don't quite know
yet these things also already exist in
the form of the Alpha class attack
submarines from the Soviet Union these
are the only subs that can outrun a
torpedo so you know that old algebra
problem if personated leaves pittsburgh
at 40 miles an hour and person B leaves
Boston at 30 miles an hour
word of the trains collide or I forget
how it actually ends well in the end if
a torpedo leaves an American sub at
whatever speed and the alpha class
submarine notices it how close do they
have to be before the torpedo runs out
of gas so what I was told by the
designer of these subs fellow and by the
name of George Ito schinsky
when he came here to talk about his
experience with his lead bismuth
reactors is there is a button on the sub
that's the forget about safety it's a
torpedo button because if you are have a
if you're underwater it'll lead bismuth
reactor and a torpedo is heading at you
you have a choice between maybe dying in
a nuclear catastrophe and definitely
dying in a torpedo explosion well that
button is the I like those odds
button and you just give full power to
the engines and whatever else happens
happens the point is you may be able to
outrun the torpedo and quite popular
nowadays especially in this department
is molten salt cooled reactors that
actually use liquid salt not dissolved
but molten salt itself as the coolant
that doesn't have as many of the
corrosion problems as lead
the exploding problems is sodium it does
have a low a high melting point problem
though they tend to melt at around 450
degrees Celsius but there's one pretty
cool feature you can dissolve uranium in
them so remember how in light water
reactors the coolant is also the
moderator in molten salt reactors the
coolant is also the fuel because you can
have principally uranium and lithium
fluoride salt Co dissolved in each other
and the way you make a reactor is you
just flow a bunch of that salt into
nearby pipes and then you get less
what's called Neutron leakage or in each
of these pipes once in awhile uranium
will give off a few neutrons most of
them will just come out the other ends
of the pipes and you won't have a
reaction when you put a whole bunch of
molten salt together
most of those neutrons find other molten
salt and the reaction proceeds and it's
got some nice AIF tea features like if
something goes wrong just break open a
pipe all the salt spills out becoming
some critical because leakage goes up it
freezes pretty quickly and then you must
deal with it but it's not a big deal to
deal with it if it's already solid and
not critical so it's actually five of
its 0 of 5 of I'll stop here Tuesday
we'll keep developing the many many
different variables we'll need to write
down the neutron transport equation at
which point you'll be qualified to read
the t-shirts that this department prints
out and then we'll simplify it so you
can actually solve the equation
you